nombre de contrats aidés répondre
véritablement des besoins prioritaires
cela il n'est pas question de les
supprimer et nous ne supprimons pas en
revanche
ayons l'honnêteté de nous dire les
choses est il normal dans des grandes
collectivités publiques je parle pas de
petites communes rurales je parle de
grandes collectivités publiques france
urbaine
ces 2000 communes pour l'essentiel ce
sont des grandes collectivités publiques
est il normal mesdames et messieurs que
des emplois pérennes et jugé
indispensable au fonctionnement de
services publics soient gérées à coups
de contrats aidés
je crois pas très franchement je crois
en tout cas c'est pas ma conviction et
olam mur au-delà de l'urgence des jours
et des semaines à venir
nous avons donc décidé d'une part de
revenir à l'esprit originel des contrats
aidés en les recentrant sur les publics
les plus en vue est éloigné pardon de
l'emploi la ministre du travail a
d'ailleurs mentionné jean marc borello
président du groupe sos pour rencontrer
les acteurs de l'insertion et formuler
des propositions et d'autre part de
porter nos efforts sur des dispositifs
plus efficace capable de sortir
durablement du chômage des personnes les
moins qualifiées